I'm not going to spend a lot of time on  a on this very powerful erection yes but  Herschel Walker flanked last night on  Fox news by Senator Lindsey Graham and  Senator Ted Cruz  said that what's happening in Georgia  this erection is about the people  first of all this election is more than  Herschel Walker Resurrection is about  the people  want to hear it one more time  well first of all this election is more  than the Herschel Walker this direction  is about the people yeah Ted Cruz  visibly moving his eyes and then trying  to play it cool listen I don't really  have much else to say about this for a  guy who impregnated so many women and  then urged them to get abortions this is  quite the Freudian slip vote Raphael  Warnock on December 6th